for eight years Hugh Laurie starred in
the title role in the Fox medical drama
house but despite becoming an
international celebrity he isn't chasing
success for its own sake he is why he
hasn't been the same since house for an
actor not every day on the job is
glamorous and exciting sometimes they
can feel a little repetitive so after
nearly a decade playing dr. Gregory
House Hugh Laurie definitely wanted a
change of scenery he still enjoyed
playing the role all the way through to
the final season but the routine was
starting to get monotonous and he wasn't
sure if he was really cut out for that
kind of commitment anymore as the final
season was airing he told The Telegraph
you know we have done 170 episodes now I
think that's about 50 to 60 feature
films worth you want to break you really
do
so Laurie's first order of business
after house wrapped was to take a long
break from acting he ended up spending a
full three years away from Hollywood
save for a few small exceptions like
lending his voice of video game
LittleBigPlanet 3 he finally got back in
front of the camera in 2015 for the
Disney film Tomorrowland he loved
playing house but he often felt like he
was working himself to the bone on set
getting up at 5 a.m. for a 16-hour work
day was not uncommon when he stuck with
his schedule for nearly a decade no
wonder he needed an extended vacation
once the cameras stopped rolling how are
things in hell is the humidity the big
issue although Laurie would certainly
have preferred more privacy than the
press afforded him after the success of
house the overwhelming praise for the
series gave him a major confidence boost
after all he'd never been part of such
an internationally successful show
before previously he occasionally felt
insecure about his career because he'd
never gone to drama school and wondered
if he wasn't a genuinely qualified actor
Laurie used to question whether or not
he really belongs in the entertainment
industry
but once Hal sarkoff with audiences and
he saw the impact the show was having he
realized that it definitely earned his
place
it was a huge turning point in his
career as he told the Guardian House was
something I didn't have to apologize for
it was something I was really proud of
and whether you liked it or not it was
undeniable although Laurie wasn't acting
much right after house went off the air
he didn't completely stop working he
just chose to invest his time in a
different creative pursuit it turns out
he's a talented blues musician and he
loves recording music even more than he
loves acting in 2011 Laurie released let
them talk its first blues album he was
surprised by the success achieved and he
he went on to release a second album in
2013 entitled it didn't of rain he
admitted that he was quite nervous in
the recording studio but as it turned
out he had nothing to be worried about
his concerts sold out and the albums
were certified gold he told the Guardian
in 2013 there's a sensual pleasure
involved in making sounds harmonious
sounds that I just can't get and I don't
think anyone can quite get from acting
it just cannot get better than that
it takes over my whole body in a way
that acting just can't dr. Gregory House
was known for being prickly and brutally
honest but it would be tough to argue
that he was a villain despite his rough
exterior he had a kind heart and he
genuinely wanted to help his patients
but the actor who played him eventually
wanted to play a truly evil character in
2016 Hugh Laurie finally got the chance
when he landed the role of Richard
Roeper on the BBC series the night
manager based on john lecarre a's novel
of the same name the plot follows a
former soldier who manages to worm his
way into ropers in a circle as Roper is
aiming the Egyptian government in the
midst of the Arab Spring
at one point Roper is described as the
worst man in the world and Laurie was up
for the challenge of bringing this vile
character to life he told The Telegraph
villainy serves a purpose and all good
storytelling it's a very well trodden
path in all kinds of stories so when I
was offered the chance to play Roper
there was no way I could possibly pass
it up a life depends on the quality of
your performance in the next half-hour
so smile after eight years of playing
house
Laurie knew that he could easily land
another doctor role if he wanted to but
he felt like doing so would mean he was
basically putting himself in a box but
when he was offered the part of doctor
Eldon chance on the Hulu series chance
he just couldn't pass it up
when Astin a 2016 interview with junkie
if he hesitated before taking another
medical role he answered for about two
minutes
I opened the script and thoughts oh this
is good it's a shame I can't do it
because it's medical after three pages
are forgotten
Laurie made an exception this time a
constructed shunt was a different type
of doctor who was dealing with very
different patients than dr. house was
you know I'm not a treating therapist
I'm a consulting or a psychiatrist sense
of the medical drama and a suspenseful
thriller all wrapped up in one and
Laurie didn't feel like he was playing
the same role all over again overall
he's certainly changed in the years
since the house finale but the
authenticity that he brings there
Rolle still makes them one of the best
actors in the business check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
actors are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]